this story about the hero in the mall in
indiana
just gets better and better
so there was a potential mass shooter in
this mall in indiana and he did sadly
manage to kill three people
and he injured some other people
but he only killed three people and he
only injured i think five or so other
people because he was taken out not by
the police
not by gun control laws
but by a good guy with a gun
a young good guy with a gun who was only
carrying a gun because of the
constitutional carry laws in indiana so
that's what we knew about the story
now it gets even better
22 years old
guy's name is elisha dicken
and he's walking around the mall with
his girlfriend
she spots the bad guy with the gun she
says i see a long rifle over there he
tells her get down do not get up
he
gets behind some kind of edifice a pole
or something to that effect to give him
a little bit more balance and a little
bit of cover
and he fires off 10 rounds from his
glock so he empties the magazine on the
glock
he hits the guy some reports are saying
he hit the guy
some some reports are saying he hit the
guy with all all of the bullets i can't
imagine that's the case
some are saying he hit him multiple
times some some are saying he only hit
him once
all it takes is one hit the craziest
part here is
this kid this 22 year old with a glock
with a pistol in a combat situation hit
the bad guy from 40 yards away 40 yards
away
if any of you
have
any experience with firearms or maybe
you go to the range you know that is not
an easy thing to do
it's not an easy thing to do in the most
peaceful tranquil
tranquil conditions of a gun range much
less in a combat situation apparently
while the kid was firing he was he he
made sure that it was clear behind the
bad guy so he wasn't going to
accidentally pop off a good guy and he
was waving for the civilians in the mall
to get behind him and to to exit
this kid
handled himself
perfectly and he took some amazing shots
he has no training with the police he
has no training with the military
he learned how to shoot from his grandpa
the reason this story really matters
other than it's amazing and they should
make a action movie out of it or
something is
everybody did everything right here
because by the way the girlfriend then
who the hero boyfriend saved she's
apparently a nurse she goes and
immediately starts tending to people and
caring for people and then we only know
about this because she called her
grandmother the grandmother would talk
to the reporters and the grandmother
said you know look
this is amazing we're so proud of the
guy we're so proud of my granddaughter
but it's it's going to be hard for this
guy because taking on a human life even
if it's a guilty life even if it's a
potential mass killer that's a hard
thing to do so please pray for him
please pray for everyone involved and i
read this story and i say wow everybody
did everything right
other than the mass shooter obviously
everybody did everything right the kid
who killed the shooter
the girlfriend who tended to the injured
people and the grandmother who said just
pray please pray i'm praying you should
pray too prayers are efficacious
everyone did everything right my biggest
takeaway from this story
is that
not that these people got lucky not what
a miracle it was though i'm you know in
a way it certainly does seem miraculous
but what doesn't seem the part that
actually makes it seem not like a
miracle is that kid was prepared it's
not just that he was carrying his gun
around
not just that he was flaunting his
rights
that kid had earned the right to keep
and bear arms that kid was exercising
his right responsibly that kid had
trained that kid knew how to use it
same thing is true of guns as is true of
other
features of life it's not the size
necessarily that matters it's how you
use it
okay it seems you can tell that with a
gun he just had a little glock on him
but he knew how to use it he was very
well trained he was being a very
responsible citizen this girl was being
a very responsible citizen
that's a lesson that we should all
learn okay
if we want our rights
because this this story completely
undercuts the lib's arguments for gun
control completely undercuts
the the
narrative that they've been pushing very
hard for a couple of months now
but
but they've been pushing it for years
actually
if we want our rights we need to know
how to use them if we want to be a free
people and we want to have
self-government we need to be capable of
that
this is why
we go back to this john adams quote a
lot but
one of the implications of the john
adams quote when he says the
constitution is built for a moral and
religious people that's unfit to the
government of any other kind of people
similar quotes from other founding
fathers about how if we don't
practice our
liberty if we don't practice the virtues
if we are not worthy of our liberty we
will lose it we will lose the ability
for self-government that's just a fact
that's how it goes if people are not
virtuous if people are not living up to
their liberty if they trade their
liberty for licentiousness then they're
going to
have have a master they're going to be
in need of a master they're going to
deserve a master they're not going to
have their rights this is a really
really great story and it backs up a
poll that just came out there's a poll
from the convention of states action and
trafalgar group
that surveyed americans of all political
persuasions and asked who do you trust
more
in a mass shooting situation
the feds
local police
or armed civilians
and the poll was taken i believe before
this shooting happened or before the
news reports of the shooting happened
who do you think won
well let me ask you
you're in a mass shooting situation what
would make you feel better you've got
local police nearby you've got the feds
showing up at some point or you've got a
good guy who's trained a civilian with a
gun what would make you feel better
it's easy and the the
majority of people surveyed gave the
same answer the good civilian with the
gun right now text knolls to 989898
the latest inflation numbers are in
not looking good okay we've hit a
40-year high at 9.1 percent thanks to
the geniuses in the white house right
now our nation's authorities are openly
admitting that they completely blew it
quote i was wrong about the path
inflation would take that those aren't
my words i was right about what would
happen with inflation those are the
words of treasury secretary janet yellen
she said quote there have been
unanticipated and large shocks to the
economy that have boosted energy and
food prices and supply bottlenecks that
have affected our economy badly that at
the time i didn't fully understand
unanticipated by whom by you guys not by
us that's why it's so important to
protect yourself you cannot rely on the
experts and the authorities when it
comes to your wealth when it comes to
your assets it's why you've got to go
check out birch gold you should invest
at least some of your money in gold and
silver and i would strongly recommend
the birch gold group protect your
savings from a highly turbulent economy
by diversifying your 401k or ira into
physical gold it's not too late best
time to do it was yesterday second best
time to do it is today text knowles
298-9898 get a free info kit on
diversifying and protecting your savings
with precious metals birch gold has an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five-star reviews
thousands of satisfied customers text
k-n-w-l-e-s to 98 98 98 get real advice
from birch gold today that is knowles
text it to 989898 claim your free no
obligation info kit on protecting your
savings with gold
who do you trust in a mass shooting 41.8
percent of respondents say
armed citizens
25.1 percent
of respondents say the local police
10.3 percent of respondents say federal
agents
then a fifth of the people choose none
of the above
some people are surprised by this answer
what do you mean you trust some wild
american with a gun rather than the
police yes of course first of all the
libs have been telling us for years now
that the police are evil racist nazis
who just go hunting innocent black men
for sport
the police are so unspeakably evil
that's why we need to give them a
monopoly on the weapons does that make
sense no of course not
if anything the anti-cop argument is
going to increase one's faith in the
second amendment and one's reliance on
the second amendment but there's an even
more basic reason here
which is the principle of subsidiarity
it is good as a matter of government to
have
the
broadest number of decisions that can be
responsibly made the the greatest amount
of power that can be responsibly
exercised at the most local level
possible
and then certain things that the local
level can't accomplish you go up to a
higher level you go from the township to
the state maybe with the county and to
the state and to the federal government
and when we want to protect ourselves we
can't merely rely on i don't know the
fbi
jumping out of a helicopter and saving
us at our mall shooting in indiana
we can't and we can't even just rely on
the state police and we can't even rely
on the county police and we can't
necessarily even just rely on the local
police we need to be able to protect
ourselves because self-defense
is a natural right
and this is
one of the reasons why our constitution
recognizes the right to keep and bear
arms the geniuses and the pundit class
who are shocked by this who want to take
away all your guns they don't understand
this very basic principle
that at least a plurality of americans
do understand i'm glad you like that
clip we are
so close to a million subscribers i'm
very excited for this because then i'll
get my gold plaque and then youtube will
nuke me and they'll cast me into the
outer darkness and wailing and gnashing
of teeth and if that's what's gonna
happen so be it darn it make sure that
you ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications get me my gold play button
statue we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]